now to this year's local hero in the
Australia Day Awards Western Sydney
maths teacher
Eddie Wu began posting mass videos
online on YouTube in 2012 for a student
who was absent because of his cancer
treatments his site Wu tube now boasts
100 thousand subscribers and has
attracted more than 8 million views
worldwide he's made mathematics less
scary and accessible for so many
including some adults I know Eddie Wu
joins us now from Canberra Eddie Wu good
morning and congratulations thank you so
much it's absolutely great to be here
look it's an amazing life and career
that you have and I was so interested to
learn that um there were you're a
brilliant young student and there were
very high expectations of you and
normally proud parents start thinking
along the lines of doctor lawyer and the
like but you always wanted to go down a
different path didn't you I did want to
make sure that whatever I did in my life
it was a way that I could use my gifts
to be able to serve the community around
me and even though once upon a time that
dream was to be a firefighter you know
having chronic asthma kind of took the
air out of that dream when I realized
that I loved helping people learn and
that it's just an unending privilege to
be able to interact with young people
and help them grow flourish and find
their place out in the world in the
community it's just a huge privilege
that I just couldn't resist as a teacher
when did you first encounter that phobia
that so many of us have about
mathematics that becomes that
intellectual block and and what did you
think of it and you can see that look in
a student's eye they're terrified of
this to be honest the first time I
encountered that phobia was when I was
back at school
experiencing mathematics myself yeah it
wasn't my favorite subject it wasn't my
best subject English in history were the
things that I would have counted is my
strengths and that's actually part of
the journey that I've taken to learning
that you know what if mathematics wasn't
my strong suit
but through going to university and
actually getting a mathematics degree
through hard work and perseverance and
the support of others I was able to come
to that understanding that's a huge part
of why I know I believe even when the
students themselves are convinced
otherwise that everyone can learn
mathematics and it's something for all
of us to enjoy and embrace the story of
the origins of Wu tube which is you know
internationally celebrated now
he's a really wonderful one share that
with us how did it begin look five years
ago you mentioned a little bit of this
before I had a student of mine he was
just 16 years old and he was diagnosed
with pancreatic cancer which most people
will know is an incredibly violent
aggressive disease you know three to six
months is the kind of prognosis you
would expect and I knew that this boy
was going to be missing weeks and weeks
of school for for treatment even after
his treatment the recovery because of
his immune system and I thought it would
just be a tragedy if I got a textbook
set it in his hands and said you know
we'll see you in a month have a go at
chapter five and good luck and
mathematics is the kind of subject where
some of us to really sit alongside you
help you understand what the concepts
mean and how they connect to your life
and to each other and so I thought look
we have technology now that can help us
do better than this I just got my phone
out of my pocket the quality was an
amazing that you could see the
whiteboard you could hear my voice and I
only had this one boy in mind so I
wasn't really all that concerned and I
hit record in the middle of one of my
just regular lessons with his class
while they are at school and the rest is
history it certainly is and you gave a
wonderful speech last night where you
are you brought together mathematics and
poetry and what it is to be Australian
and I just want to quote one line from
it last night where you said it's also
strange for me to be the one standing
here today being a person who was
harassed and isolated for not being
Australian and that speaks to a a really
important part of what we also have to
recognize on Australian to Australia day
that it's been a difficult journey for
for those who are who are different I
mean diversity is both the hardest and
best part about Australian society you
know like Martin Luther King jr. said we
might have all come here in different
ships but now we're all in the same boat
and I think that that while it presents
huge challenges in sort of reckoning
with diversity and it's something we
have to learn afresh every new
generation it has to work out ok what
does it mean to get along with people
who think differently to me believe
different things who speak differently
but actually going through that process
is so transformative it's one of the
things that makes me so passionate about
being a teacher because I get to see
young people wrestle with that actually
come to a deeper and richer
understanding
their ownselves and identity through
being with others who are different but
that difficult process that you spoke
about there about the harassed and
isolator do you think it it took more
from you or gave you more I would never
wish that experience on anyone but when
I look back I definitely recognize that
through going through that experience
that was really formative for me to
recognize that you know I I don't hold
it against any of the my peers who acted
in that way because I know that they
were themselves trying to work out who
they were and what their place in the
world was and it's a very natural human
instinct to be afraid of things that are
different and to try and shore up your
own identity and say it what we're not
like that
but that's why I feel so strongly about
children having that great foundation
you know families are a huge part of how
children learn this but summer schools I
mean hundreds and thousands of hours of
what our young people spend in their
schooling career and so it's just an
opportunity that we can't miss to help
our young people grow in society and
this year then Eddie we're just finally
this morning what does it mean for you
how will you spend it I'm really looking
forward to the opportunities I'll have
to help people recognize the enduring
value of education which in a country
like this we often forget since it's so
easily accessible to us and I also am on
a mission to help people have a
different view of what mathematics is
that it really is more than just numbers
it can be a beautiful subject that's
practical and useful to all of us and I
want to help people have a new concept
and change their perspective on it Eddie
congratulations we're really pleased for
you enjoy this year coming coming up is
going to be a terrific one for you and
your students thank you thank you so
much it's been a pleasure